[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de France 24 sobre el Éxodo nos
saluda Juliette riaño
[Música]
el cambio en las políticas de los
gobiernos no detiene el tránsito de
personas hacia un lugar más seguro tras
el fin del título 42 los migrantes que
viajan rumbo a Estados Unidos avanzan a
lo que consideran su sueño americano la
Península de Yucatán en México una ruta
poco común para ellos se ha convertido
en una vía de paso en las últimas
semanas las autoridades locales
encontraron en circulación a más de 300
migrantes por lo que ahora implementan
operativos armados con drones y cámaras
infrarrojas para rastrearlos el informe
es de Katy Espinoza la Península de
Yucatán en el sureste de México se ha
convertido en las últimas semanas en un
nuevo y Máximo paso de migrantes en
busca del sueño americano José dejó su
natal El Salvador hace tres meses la
falta de trabajo liso abandonar su país
le vendieron una nueva ruta alterna y
más segura para llegar a los Estados
Unidos
más seguros más rápido eso lo dijeron a
nosotros que era un camino que a
nosotros no nos mostraban seguridad en
la de Yucatán se han encendido las
alarmas por el paso de indocumentados se
Han detenido a más de 300 migrantes no
solo de Centroamérica sino de lugares
lejanos como Haití República Dominicana
India y hasta Turquía este Refugio apoya
con el resguardo de migrantes detenidos
porque las instalaciones del Instituto
Nacional de Migración han sobrepasado su
capacidad ante la inusitada o la de
indocumentados detenidos y a raíz de las
caravanas los migrantes
alternas
que aunque la Península está ubicada
Digamos como que en una forma No tan
estratégica para los migrantes pero los
migrantes digamos que sorteando o
evitando los
puntos de contención el levantamiento
del título 42 en Estados Unidos ha
impulsado aún más la llegada de miles de
migrantes desde la frontera sur de
México
Nicaragua Honduras tenemos Esa esa fe de
que sí se va a lograr ese artículo sí es
como un sueño otro sueño nuevo sueño
para nosotros como el primero que
teníamos llegar a Estados Unidos un
sueño americano este sueño nos sentimos
casi seguro en la Península de Yucatán
se han reforzado operativos de seguridad
para detectar a personas que viajan sin
documentos en las carreteras de la
entidad el temor es no poder manejar la
migración en masa Mientras tanto el
gobierno de Estados Unidos hace un nuevo
llamado a los migrantes advierte que el
levantamiento del título 42 no significa
que la frontera esté abierta y reiteró
que quienes crucen de forma irregular
serán procesados y no podrán volver en
cinco años pero aunque el destino para
muchos es Estados Unidos la llegada allí
no es fácil para todos un grupo de
migrantes venezolanas que habló con
nuestro corresponsal en la capital
estadounidense cuestiona el sueño
americano y pide a las autoridades
condiciones dignas para vivir que ha
pasado con ellas nos lo cuenta Cristóbal
Vázquez en el siguiente informe
tras el levantamiento del título 42
algunas migrantes venezolanas cuentan su
difícil experiencia de vida en Estados
Unidos cuestionan El sueño americano y
piden a las autoridades en Washington
condiciones de vida dignas esta mujer de
las costas venezolanas que no su nombre
por seguridad al llegar a Washington
ubicada en un hotel abandonado que
reabrió para acoger migrantes pero
reclama que las condiciones de vida son
precarias bueno en cuanto a la
alimentación no es digna para un ser
humano ni para un adulto ni para un niño
y en cuanto las camas Bueno ya son como
camas ya muy obsoletas y en cuanto la
parte de la higiene con las sábanas y
los paños no es la adecuada
al menos 12.000 migrantes han sido
enviados en autobuses desde Texas y
Arizona a Washington y según la oficina
de Servicios al migrante la ciudad no
tiene más albergues para recibirlos esta
otra venezolana que viajó desde Ecuador
pide una identificación para
independizarse y dejar de ser una carga
en realidad que quiere trabajar Busca
manera de hacerlo como sea y nosotros
los venezolanos pues Considero que somos
bastante guerreros y no nos paramos por
algo como eso pero si sería de bastante
ayuda porque quizás podríamos optar a
mejores sueldos pues para Diana fula
organizadora comunitaria de la ong
la falta de papeles de los migrantes
hace que algunas empresas se aprovechen
de ellos
de de robo de salario
lo escucho todos los días y es otra cosa
que queremos trabajar también porque así
las personas no tengan documentos para
trabajar
Ellos tienen derechos y si los contratan
para trabajar tienen que pagarles lo
justo Estas mujeres quieren seguir
trabajando hasta lograr una vida digna e
independiente pero están lejos de
alcanzarla porque siguen en manos de las
autoridades locales así las cosas el
futuro de miles de personas siguen manos
de las decisiones de los gobiernos Lo
cierto es que la migración no se
detendrá como tampoco se detienen las
causas que los motivan a salir de sus
países de origen y el dato de migración
de la semana el número de migrantes que
cruza el tapón del daría en El Paso
natural entre Colombia y Panamá hacia
Centroamérica podría alcanzar un récord
este año según la agencia de la ONU para
los refugiados los datos de 2023 son
mucho mayores a los reportados hasta
mayo de 2022 según reportes oficiales de
las autoridades panameñas en los
primeros cuatro meses del año en curso
las cifras se multiplicaron hasta por 6
hasta que inmigrantes de France 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrante cf24
sigan con más información en France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]